I've been known to game from abandon his
game welcome to gain Central Station
becoming everything changes now it
seemed like that'd be cool to do like a
movie about the secret world of video
games and what they're like behind the
scenes but but within it you know I was
looking for that one little you know
story of well what would be interesting
about that you know and video game
characters really have no choice or pre
will but what they do their program to
do one job and that's pretty much it for
their whole life and I thought well what
would it be like you know if one of
those characters decided to get a had
enough I don't want to be the bad guy
anymore but if the guy who had the worst
job in the game was kind of the bad guy
you know character decided he wants the
good life like the hero character ralphs
gaunt a hero's duty goes often goes into
these other video games in the arcade
which is forbidden among video game
characters sugar rush your game jumping
huge you know like portion of developing
the movie was just like how do we how do
we portray these different worlds so
they're so they're true so the genres
that because everyone knows what those
you know worlds feel like alpha Ralph we
get it but we can't change who we are
and the sooner you accept that the
better off your game and your life will
be